and I went into the place and got a her
they gave me all this [__] for the free
because I just they you when you Muslim
you get whatever then we went to the
little Mediterranean place they gave me
a free salad no way y the benefits are
coming in all pres of the most
high the I ad you're about to see is for
adults only if you're a child please
tune off it's a medical condition that
can affect everyone and it is halal and
permissible lock down pills for the
moment when you're not feeling up for it
available in both male and female 100%
authentic natural intimacy vitility
pills endorsed in TV's this morning
celebrity Dr Chris Steel issue of the
celebrity Angels magazine by aagra also
if you provide a festar review after
your purchase on Amazon you can qualify
for a fee pack terms and conditions
apply brothers and sisters and dear
friends today's video as you guys know
it's not regarding Palestine done many
many videos on the topic Etc but yeah
today's video is something that I saw
and again you know with us you know our
job is s remind cuz reminder benefits a
Believer this was sent to me to ca jabby
on the fresh and fit podcast that they
do I just wanted to look at it because
to me it was a a bit distasteful but
obviously there's some context before
anybody goes on a mad one and starts
back biting sland whatever for that
matter that's not the aim of this video
it's the first day she's wearing the
hijab but there's so many lessons to be
learned from this I haven't seen this
video you haven't so you're saying it's
the first day she's wearing the yeah
when I heard that I was like okay at
least that's the reason why you're
behaving that bu uh you ready I'm ready
as um are you on birth control no okay
if a baby pop out I'm keeping it okay
that's you
and I got a four-month old shout out to
KI the Mother of Dragons [__] yes I
Nam my baby after the mother of
drag I'm a mother of three by the way I
got three you just can't see it under
this little
dress it's my
my wow it's her first I went to Japan in
before she called me to invite me I was
walking out of Japan in and my fiance
who was on the fence about being Muslim
he ran into one of his Muslim brothers
and I asked him like how long what do
you got to do to be musim he said we can
get on the phone right now and do your
sh up do it yeah and then he and then I
went into the place and got a her they
gave me all this [__] for the free
because I just they you when you Muslim
you get whatever then we went to the
little Mediterranean place they give me
a free salad no way y the benefits are
coming
in to
the [__] on the question what's [__] my
body kind of hurt [__] I don't even
know you talking about but when you do
shahada you start over [__] right now
right now I'm a
virgin virgin okay so it's your first
day converting um what only a few hours
so go easy on me no no no I'm not going
to I just I'm just curious like what
made you uh want to convert oh well my
fiance was on the fence about it because
he believed in God but he didn't know
which religion to pick and I was like
just go whichever won um I'm baptized
Christian and I'm also in centeria AKA
EPA if you're African so I was like
let's do Muslim okay let's do it all
like just f
it follow a God that's what it matter
only one God at the end of the day
anyway and every single one of the
religions that I'm in they have a one
God that's one God we all no matter what
race you are from the same was a
specific reason just or it was
reallyy I I want a man who gonna lead so
I'm telling him pick a religion whatever
one you want to do I'm going to do I'll
do all of them if you want do all of
them I'll do one if you want to do one
and you know being a Muslim is a little
more disciplined than all the other yeah
that's why he's on the fence about it
but I just want to show him like I'mma
jump in it first both feet in so you can
feel a little confident like you just
said you want a man of leads yeah I was
say but but he did it too he did as
right but as soon as some people need
that extra push no you're leading him
literally right what are you doing but
everything else he leads that's what I'm
saying he already lives his life like a
Muslim man because you said that you got
pregnant in high school your high school
swe no he's not he's my third baby daddy
my high school sweetheart was a bum my
high school sweetheart was a bum and my
second baby daddy is in jail for murder
so my third is the only one like third
time is a charm
bro wa wait too much unack straight you
baby daddies one's in jail three baby
daddi one's a dead beat and one's there
right now one is the one bro you see the
ring
y for
murder so my son's dad was my high
school sweetheart yeah and my second
baby daddy two years in he got the FED
game and got Chris what's going on
bro mural homicide free him he ain't
mean to do
it what these [__] do before you have
babies with them you got to run a
background check on [__] before you
them because I a plan for that [__] my
daughter hasn't seen her dad since she
was 10 months and been Lo she's seven
she's seven now I see I think I that was
a bit painful to watch anyways in a
nutshell I don't know what you make out
of it but I'll be honest with you it is
all over the place in America girls come
from a certain background Etc they're a
bit rough around the edges a bit too
rough so I don't know there's a few
things that I can learn from this number
one as a new Muslim if you're are a
woman or a man focus on yourself take a
good couple of months out a year out
because there's a lot of baggage you're
coming with a lot of jilia um times of
ignorance that you're bringing in like
for for example for me the fact that
she's there wearing a hijab spewing you
know swearing talking about her past
past sins oh I didn't smash myON and did
you get it so again you can excuse her
that in the sense where it's her first
day you can genuinely excuse her because
it's like she does not anything so you
really cannot blame her but it's just so
painful to watch a hijabi on that show
talking about her past talking about oh
I was a [__] before talk I I'm being
honest with you I'm thinking how does
non a non-muslim man who she's
apparently married or going to marry
who's again I think they're both Muslims
their stages Etc I understand but I mean
your girl your wife talking about this
typically speaking whenever you're
learning something you have a teacher
for example if you're learning to drive
you get a driving instructor if you're
you know learning to become an
electrician you go and you study with
somebody you know who knows about
electrics so similarly with Islam when
you accept Islam you know learn under a
teacher um sometimes the person that
gives you shahada somebody that gives
you da yeah invites you keep you know in
contact with them and ask them for
classes ask them for resources I think
that's what majority of the reverts or
converts actually do they do actually
refer to teachers however this girl over
here it it didn't didn't seem like she
came with that Zeal it was like oh all
of them believeing a God one is you know
more disciplined I'll just go with this
one although she's adorning the hijab
but it seems like you know what I mean
like it's clear from what she said
that's not really where she's coming
from and for her to come on a podcast
and start you know you you're adorning
the uniform of religious women it comes
with you know even if you don't
understand there's there's a degree of
rationality and logic that I'm wearing a
uniform of somebody I need to treat it
with respect so if you don't know then
you know you're wearing the hijab you're
CL you're saying you're a Muslim you're
effing blinding talk talking about how
many how much you smashed and it's it
just doesn't suit it doesn't suit what
you're going into like for a serious
student that's embraced the religion
again you're supposed to be a student
you're you're learning you're not
supposed to go on there and you know
like you said that sort of behavior even
if a person doesn't know bro logically
it's not befitting yeah so yeah you're
right you know like first thing I'll say
she said oh the following day I'm going
to start praying look at the end of the
day we're not telling you just cuz you
said things which which again is totally
against Islam we're not telling you oh
now you cannot wear the hijab keep your
hijab on nobody say to take it off we're
just saying it's a gradual process for
you to go on the show wearing a hijab
for the first day and talking about all
this kind of stuff ET I think it would
been uncomfortable it's a general
message to people that are accepting
Islam this is just an example and a
study General yes so yeah we're just be
very careful and not only that uh this
shows us that to out appearance I mean
if we saw the sister out on the streets
we would never ever think that there's
this trauma background baggage all that
comes with it it's very important that
as new Muslims or Muslims who are
starting to to practice again that you
start take a couple of years out or even
a year and detox yourself rehab you know
cuz you come with same with me it came
with a lot of baggages bad habits and
you know what we want to send this
sister a prayer mat yeah because Salah
plus uh we help born Muslims and new
Muslims how to pray Salah Salah plus.com
guys you can for free go there if you
want to book an instructor if you want
to learn how to pray Salah we've got
videos and if you want to order we want
to send her a guided prayer mat which
shows her how to pray at the end again
she's our sister yes it was very
distasteful it's her first day we can
assume the best in that because it's her
literally she said it's her first day
maybe she doesn't understand the whole
concept no problem but it's an example
for us to all understand just because
somebody observes the hijab or just
because um they're wearing a phobe or a
beard or whatever for that matter it
does not mean don't make this mistake a
lot of people make this mistake in the
marriage seeking process where they look
at a person and how they look the outter
appearance and they make a judgment oh
you you don't know nothing about them I
don't care if they wear aab I don't care
if they have a mortal bag helmet I don't
care if they got a beard that's up to
their feet it means nothing there's
verse in the Quran where Allah tells you
to look at the tawa so it's very
important to not make these decisions
based on appearance because believe me
there are a lots of people out there who
have troubles who have traumas who have
baggage Etc and they just put a hijab on
and you're thinking that's the only
thing you see is that of course the B
and the hijab it's not you're not saying
that of it means nothing what you're
saying is don't don't take don't make
judgments based on the face value
somebody with a beard of course that's
that's rewarding you're
doing you're following you know an of
Quran and you know you're doing what
your creator has told you however you
know with that comes a person's actions
as well with that you know it's
important to look at a person's
character and not just to rely on one's
appearance yes and when it comes to
marriage you do not make a marriage
decision based on what they were what
they look like you can look at them and
be like I admire the fact that you wear
a hijab I admire that you got a beard
big up all day every day but you do not
make a marriage decision this is
fundamental what a lot of people making
a mistake which I'll be throughout this
whole year I'm heavily focusing on
projects that I'm be launching
pertaining to helping you guys into the
marage can process ni which is involved
as well in but that aside we would
like to send the sister a guided prayer
mat check Salah plus.com if you guys
want to check out as well an audio
prayer map please do and uh yes again
guys please please please inshallah make
Dua that Allah subhana tala guys our
sister makes a FM and her husband and
inshallah this video is taken down even
myON said you know I don't like look at
woman in hijab in that way which I I
respect and admire even though he says
he's outright he doesn't practice and
all this kind stuff that he does fact he
show he's a smart guy and you know
know everyone's a specif written for
them of wey our but you know what
honestly you know seeing the isms and
the schisms out there even those people
that leave Islam there is nothing else
out there like Islam is the one that's
Head and Shoulders Above the Rest when
you look at the preservation of the book
when you look at the and the practice
when you look at you know every aspect
Islam shines the brightest so I have no
doubt that these people eventually will
come back but we need to make sure that
when they come back you're the person
that they're going to be calling you're
the person that they're going to be
saying you know what this but if you've
cut off relations if you have you know
soured uh you know relations between you
guys they say don't ruin relations
between people such that if tomorrow the
time comes to rekindle ties you're able
to and don't befriend somebody so much
that if tomorrow you become enemies they
know your deepest darker secret so there
is a balance so even here as well if you
see somebody going off the path you know
still give them that dignity that
respect and you know speak sometimes
people want to maintain distance because
they say either you give da you get
given da so they don't want to receive
da some people can maintain those
relationships and give dawa so it's very
important how you address such people if
you can give dawa with hikma and
beautiful preaching that the Quran says
alhamdulillah all well and good if not
with all du respect pass the Baton on to
somebody else exactly exactly that's all
I have to say brother sister inallah I
hope this message reaches the sister and
we can send a dis guided prayer M and it
connects her to her Lord which is most
powerful thing in which is the second
pillar of Islam which is Salah till next
time